Welcome, students, to the
Pharmacology of the NSAIDs,
Part 2. In this video, I will
describe the pharmacology
of the individual drugs.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Please contact me if you'd
like to talk pharmacology.
Here are the learning
objectives and preparation
materials. I strongly recommend
that you do the practice
questions you can learn new
material any way you like
links to resources if you
would choose to use them and
the key points for aspirin
I've tried to put them in
brief bullet points so that
you could get the big ideas,
and non-aspirin NSAIDs,
adverse effects,
populations,
and acetaminophen.
So let us begin with aspirin.
Aspirin is
acetylsalicylic acid.
Salicylate, or salicylic
acid, is not acetylated.
We'll be talking about the
actions of salicylic acid
because it is the active
metabolite of aspirin.
Beginning with
pharmacokinetics of
these two, they're
quite different.
Looking at aspirin first
comes ****** or rectally.
rapid absorption
from the upper small
intestine except rectally
of course it doesn't reach
the upper small intestine.
It can also pass
through stomach tissues
into the local bloodstream
that is not the major
root of absorption.
It distributes into
platelets in the portal
circulation. This is
related to one of its
effects. I should say
one of its therapeutic
uses, which is its
antiplatelet effect.
It is rapidly
metabolized by esterases.
These esterases are located
in many, many, many tissues,
including the gut mucosa,
red blood cells, the
blood itself, liver, synovial
fluid. The active metabolite,
as I mentioned earlier,
Here is salicylic acid.
Unchanged aspirin
reaches the systemic
circulation and is
rapidly hydrolyzed. It's
only got about a 20
-minute half-life.
What's the relevance here?
I'm taking you back to
the distribution into the
platelets in the portal
circulation. This is the major
area where low-dose aspirin
enters platelets because
of its rapid half-life.
Once it gets to the systemic
circulation, it doesn't
stay around long.
Well, what about
salicylic acid? This
compound itself is not
administered ******
or intravenously.
It's very irritating.
However, salicylic acid from
aspirin is widely distributed,
crosses the blood-brain
barrier and the placenta,
binds to albumin, remembering
that it's saturable.
And another thing to remember
is that therapeutic doses,
this is one of those that
has zero order metabolism,
which I have indicated
here. This is
going to be dose
-dependent, of course.
Hepatic conjugation, the
bioavailability of
salicylic acid is
reasonable,
this being when the
systems are more saturated.
It is excreted as
salicyl, uric acid mainly.
Has a half-life of about
two to three hours with
the low dose with zero
-order kinetics. We see this
longer half-life up to
10 hours. This becomes
important, this half-life
10 hours becomes important
and toxicity and salicylate
toxicity can be deadly.
Just a little scheme of
the metabolic pathway.
This item here, sodium
salicylate, is an actual drug.
Looking at aspirin,
goes to salicylic
acid, goes to acetic
acid, and so on.
Mechanism of action? Well,
aspirin is the prototype,
but unlike other prototypes,
it's actually different
than the rest. How is it
different? By irreversible
acetylation of its target,
target being cyclooxygenases.
Aspirin covalently
acetylates a serine
residue within the
hydrophobic channel that is
near the arachidonic
acid binding sites.
By binding to this
serine residue,
it obstructs
arachidonic acid from
being able to
enter the catalytic
channel and bind to
its catalytic site.
Therefore,
prostanoid synthesis
is prevented.
Let's take a look now at
salicylic acid mechanism.
Quite a bit of research
has been done into
this mechanism. The
in vitro studies
suggest that salicylic
acid inhibits
arachidonic acid metabolism
probably, in part,
by preventing cyclooxygenase
2 promoter region.
And therefore,
cyclooxygenase transcription
is inhibited and mRNA
induction is inhibited.
Therefore, the inflammatory
upregulation of COX
-2 is suppressed.
So that's the salicylic
anti-inflammatory
mechanism, also fever,
anti-fever, and analgesic.
Salicylic acid has also been
found to be a reversible
inhibitor of the
enzymes, very weak, not
significantly, and does not
have antiplatelet effects.
So it will enter platelets
most likely, but it
won't inhibit cyclooxygenase
1 within the platelets.
Speaking of platelets,
aspirin is used largely as
an antiplatelet drug. that's
its major use nowadays
and it's used in low doses
because low doses are adequate
when given once daily so
you're thinking okay 20 minute
half-life why do we give
it only once daily because
it enters the platelet
irreversibly acetylates and
inactivates the cyclooxygenase
one within the platelet, that
will prevent the synthesis
of the prostanoid, thromboxane
A2, for the life of
the platelet. So this is a
biologic half-life that we're
talking about, which is
why it is given once daily.
The low dose enters the
circulation and will
inhibit whatever
platelets it gets to. It
won't do much within the
systemic circulation.
And so if it's given
every day, eventually
we get that adequate
antiplatelet effect.
So let's take this
one more step.
Knowing that it's going
to inhibit thromboxane A2
synthesis, knowing that it
has very little active life
within the systemic
circulation, it is not going to
be inhibiting endothelial
COX-2 to any great extent.
Therefore, the endothelial
COX-2 prostacyclin,
PGI2, is available. Remembering
that prostacyclin has
the counterbalancing
effects to thromboxane A2.
So thromboxane A2 promotes
aggregation of activated
platelets and basal constriction
in the local area to
develop that platelet plug.
Whereas, prostacycline
has the anti-aggregation,
de-aggregation effects and
causes vasodilation, and
therefore, that is the effect
that remains. It shifts
the balance to the
prostacycline effects,
antiplatelet. I mean, platelet
disaggregation, platelet
aggregation inhibiting effects.
What is it used for?
Well, aspirin is a very
good analgesic, antipyretic,
anti-inflammatory,
and of course, anti
-platelet, as we saw.
Okay, it's a great
anti-inflammatory.
Why don't we use it more often?
because of the higher risk
of GI toxicity compared with
other NSAIDs. In addition,
we have the higher frequency
of these more potentially
serious adverse effects,
metabolic acidosis, renal
dysfunction, and bleeding.
Bleeding can occur with
low-dose aspirin too, if
you can possibly read that.
Tinnitus, this buzzing
or ringing in the
ears is an early
symptom of toxicity.
Pain fever, aspirin is also
used for Kawasaki disease.
Now you may be saying that
Kawasaki disease is in kids
and kids get the fever
so why can we use aspirin
since we can't use aspirin
for children who present with
a fever who potentially have
a viral infection. Well,
Kawasaki disease is not a
viral infection. Aspirin
has been used for decades
and decades together with
intravenous immune globulin,
I have the word down here,
in the treatment of Kawasaki
disease, which can
be very serious.
Rheumatic fever, it's
an alternative to an
NSAID. An NSAID will
also work. Rheumatic
fever is a consequence
of strep throat,
a possible consequence.
Not everybody gets
it. We talked about the
antiplatelet effect,
so why? What are we
talking about here?
It's for prevention,
secondary prevention, after a
person has had an adverse
cardiac event or a ******,
myocardial infarction and
******. So to prevent further
myocardial infarction,
heart attacks, and ******.
Niacin tolerability.
Well, why are we
thinking about niacin
in the first place?
It's a B vitamin. Well,
high-dose niacin is also
given to reduce plasma
triglycerides, and that high
dose can cause PGD2 to
be released from mast
cells, and that will cause
flushing and tingling. So
if aspirin, and aspirin's
been found to work the
best, is given before
the niacin, then it will
reduce this flushing and
tingling. Is flushing and
tingling dangerous? No. And
it's short-lived, hours,
but it can be very
disturbing to the patient.
Salicylic acid itself is
used topically. it's a
caratolytic meaning which i
put the definition down here
causes softening and
shedding of the ***** outer
layer keratin of the skin
so i put some i listed some
caratolytic uses here
methyl salicylate is a
rub can be used as an
ointment a liniment
It can be in patches.
It will be absorbed
through the skin, and
it is a good analgesic.
This is the one that
smells like wintergreen.
Smells minty.
It must be kept out of
the reach of children
because it's highly toxic
if taken internally.
dose related adverse
effects bleeding
bleeding bleeding
bleeding bleeding bleeding
that is the major
adverse effect of aspirin
even at low doses it
can cause peptic ulcer
erosive gastritis even
at the lower doses this
happens by local cellular
injury actual the
acetylcylic acid toxicity
to the gastric cells.
Importantly, all NSAIDs
as described in part one
inhibit the gastroprotective
effects of prostacycline
and PGE2, and this increases
the risk of bleeding.
Patients with asthma very often
have an aspirin sensitivity.
High doses, I mentioned
tinnitus before,
vertigo, also related,
hyperventilation and
respiratory alkalosis and if
it's bad toxicity in other
words high dose we get
metabolic acidosis and
I'll go into that more
very high doses as I said
and I'll talk about that
in a later slide potentially
severe adverse effects
we're going to talk
about Rye syndrome first.
Aspirin use in children
and adolescents with a
viral illness, chicken pox
or influenza, was rarely
associated with Rye
syndrome. If a child
develops a fever, we think
that it's potentially a
viral illness and we
avoid giving aspirin. Why?
Rates of Rye syndrome
fell dramatically after
advisories in the 1980s
against aspirin use in
children with a fever. Is
there a causation? That's
never been demonstrated,
but there's no use
taking the risk because
Rye syndrome is severe.
It can be fatal, and I
put what happens here.
Encephalopathy,
liver dysfunction,
fatty infiltration
of the liver and
other viscera, and
the child can die.
Aspirin Exacerbated
Respiratory Disease, AERD.
This is the aspirin triad,
and it is not allergic.
It's a non-allergic
reaction that comes with
ingestion of aspirin. It
doesn't occur in everybody.
These are the risk factors
and the aspirin triad.
Bronchospasm or asthma.
upper and lower
respiratory tract hyper
reactivity this is
the deal chronic
rhinosinusitis put a picture
here and nasal polyposis
you can see the polyps
right here I'm circling the
red with my red pen and
hepatotoxicity this can occur
with a lot of drugs, high
-dose, chronic use, delayed
onset. It takes a while
for that toxicity to set
in. And fortunately, when
the aspirin is withdrawn,
it resolves.
Okay, let's talk about
this mechanism or
proposed mechanism of
the aspirin-exacerbated
respiratory disease, and
it can also occur with
NSAIDs, NSAID-exacerbated
respiratory disease,
N-E-R-D.
It has to do with shunting of
the substrate,
arachidonic acid.
Cyclooxygenase 1 here
on this figure gets
blocked by the NSAID,
and therefore, since
the arachidonic acid
can't go this way, it
goes this way, down the
lipoxygenase pathway.
Lepoxygenases produce
leukotrienes, and
some of those
leukotrienes are pro
-inflammatory, and that
will result in this
hyperreactivity,
bronchial hyperreactivity,
increased secretions, which
often happens together,
and it also causes
vascular permeability.
So, the result, bronchospasm,
congestion, mucus plugging.
I know this is a busy
slide. I wanted to
put it all together on
one slide rather than
making you look at
two different places.
This is salicylate toxicity.
It's called salicylism.
and I put the takeaway
on the next slide
if you want to take
a peek there first.
Acute toxicity and mild
chronic toxicity. The acute
toxicity is with an acute
ingestion of too much
aspirin. It can be intentional
or unintentional or it
can be taking aspirin,
regularly taking aspirin and
also taking other salicylate
containing products. A
lot of times people don't
realize that some of these
over-the-counter combination
products contain a
number of ingredients
including potentially aspirin.
Mild chronic toxicity this
could occur for example
with anti-inflammatory doses
taken regularly over time
or adding regular aspirin
intake together with the
combination product that
contains it. In any case,
this mild chronic
toxicity, you'll see early
symptoms here, often
goes unrecognized and
it could be attributed
to something else.
So the presentation,
early symptoms,
nausea, vomiting,
headache, dizziness,
ringing in the ears,
the tinnitus, classic,
that That should raise
your flags to think
about putting aspirin
toxicity on your list.
More significant toxicity,
now we see the deep and fast
breathing, tachypnea
and hyperpnea.
Also hyperthermia,
diaphoresis, so sweating. All
of these things, this
breathing, breathing, breathing
the heat and sweating
can lead to dehydration.
Also, we'll see altered
mental status, non
-cardiac pulmonary
edema seizures, and if
it's allowed to
continue at high levels,
coma.
So what's the mechanism here?
This is just biochemistry.
I'm sure you remember
it. its basic toxicity.
So salicylates
early on, remember,
it causes this deep breathing,
rapid deep breathing.
That's going to, because of
stimulation of the respiratory
center in the medulla.
That can cause respiratory
alkalosis as CO2
is breathed out.
Now, later, However,
uncoupling of
oxidative metabolism
is going to increase blood CO2.
That will, of course,
decrease blood pH
and progression to
metabolic acidosis.
Diagnosis, the tachypnea and
the hyperponeia, breathing
pattern, raising suspicion
of salicylate toxicity.
and tinnitus whether they
have it or not history
patient history history of
ingestion plus all of these
classic finds what are
we going to do to treat
this is the fundamental
concept we talked about in
foundations called ion trapping
with sodium bicarbonate
raising the ph of the
blood, raising the pH of
the urine, and that will
trap the salicylate in its
HA form,
and that will reduce the amount
that's going into the CNS,
and it will increase excretion
of the salicylate. So
that's one of the strategies
that's used. so to recap
here's the takeaway this
figure on the right shows
you what all the things
I said here we have the
therapeutic uses along with
the adverse effects that
occur with therapeutic uses
castric bleeding impaired
blood clotting hypersensitivity
reactions remember
all drugs can cause
hypersensitivity in the sensitive
individual higher doses we
start to see the ringing
or buzzing in the ears the
central hyperventilation
and up here at the lethal
and severe stage the
the dehydration coma and
vasomotor collapse what do
you need to know symptoms
and signs of salicylate
toxicity, you should be
able to identify these
dose-dependent effects.
You should be able to
recognize them in a case
vignette a patient presents
with and recognize
salicylate toxicity. You
should also revisit the
ion trapping mechanism that
is applied to treatment
of salicylate toxicity.
contraindications well
contraindications of all
drugs stem from their
adverse effects drug
interactions and the
comorbidities of the individual
patient clearly aspirin
should be avoided
in patients who have
gi disease because they
cause gi adverse effects
coagulation disorders
Congestive heart
failure, hypovolemia,
that's all covered in part one.
Severe hepatic
impairment, because
it does undergo
hepatic metabolism.
Renal impairment, and
drug interactions.
Contraindications. Anyone
who's had this non-allergic
aspirin or NSAID
-exacerbated respiratory
disease. I listed it down
here. patients with asthma,
patients who have rhinosinositis
with nasal polyps,
patients with acute upper
and lower hyperreactivity,
viral illness in
children and adolescents,
and elderly
patients who already
have reduced function
in many organs.
They have different
pharmacokinetic parameters
because of their age,
and they're often
taking many other drugs
and have comorbidities.
So let's do a check
your knowledge.
I invite you to pause
the computer and have
the video and have a
look at these questions.
See if you can answer
them from your memory.
How does the
structure of aspirin
relate to the
mechanism of action?
Well, aspirin is
acetylsalicylic acid. the
acetyl group is covalently
transferred to the
serine residue near the
arachidonic acid binding
site of the
cyclooxygenases. And this is
called the O-acetylserine.
That's how it binds.
Within the cyclooxygenase
hydrophobic
channel creates this
steric hindrance and
prevents arachidonic
acid from entering the
channel and reaching
its catalytic site.
What is the principle behind
aspirin's cardioprotective
effect. Why are we doing
it in the first place?
By shifting the thromboxane A2
-prostacycline balance
towards the antithrombotic
predominance of prostacycline.
And how does that
happen? By irreversibly
binding COX-1-derived
thromboxane A2 synthesis in
the platelets, which
allows unopposed COX-2
-derived prostacyclin,
platelet disaggregation,
and inhibition of
aggregation, vasodilation.
Why doesn't salicylic
acid inhibit platelet
aggregation, even
though it has analgesic,
anti-inflammatory, and
antipyretic activity?
because it only has
weak cox-inhibiting
activity and platelets
don't have a nucleus.
So, remember the
nucleus is where
the main action seems to occur.
Interference with the
promoter region, which
inhibits gene transcription
and induction of mRNA.
So I mentioned that in
relation to COX-2 before
because that's the
inflammatory cyclooxygenase,
but it happens also
within cyclooxygenase-1.
What is the most common
adverse effect of aspirin use?
GI effects.
Ulcer, bleeding, perforation.
What is AERD and risk factors?
It's non-allergic aspirin
-exacerbated respiratory
disease, and it can occur in
individuals with upper and
lower respiratory reactivity,
such as asthma patients,
chronic rhinosinusitis, and
nasal polyposis. And what
is the proposed mechanism
and its manifestations?
Inhibition of COX-1 pathway
may shunt arachidonic
acid to the lupoxygenase
pathway, resulting in
overproduction of leukotrienes,
which are pro-inflammatory
and produce upper and
lower airway inflammation,
nasal congestion, and
bronchospasm. Can non-aspirin
NSAIDs be taken by people
with a history of AERD?
No. Most non-selective
NSAIDs strongly inhibit
COX-1 and therefore will
trigger the same effect.
Selective COX-2
inhibitors, which
have really minimal, if any,
action on COX-1, have a low
potential for triggering it.
here's our little case
vignette a 22 year old
college student presents
to the university medical
center emergency department
with ringing in her
ears nausea rapid breathing
patient reports taking
a lot of aspirin not
sure how many for severe
tension headaches during
comp week on examination
she appears anxious
and mildly diaphoretic
respiratory rate 28 breaths
per minute which is high.
Pulse, 110 beats per minute,
which is tachycardia.
Arterial blood gas analysis
reveals a primary respiratory
alkalosis with a developing
high anion gap metabolic
acidosis. Serum levels
are consistent with drug
toxicity. History symptoms
and signs are consistent with
acute salicylic acid toxicity,
also known as acute salicylism.
Applying what you learned
about the behavior
of weak acids in
solution, what is the
purpose of administering
intravenous bicarbonate
to this patient,
sodium bicarbonate?
The principle of
ion trapping, and
I'll let you review
that on your own.
There are non
-acetylated salicylates.
I am not putting a star
on any of these. I'm not
asking you to memorize them.
They're not widely used.
Two of them are
available in the
United States. I've
indicated that.
The takeaway is these drugs
are rarely used and are
less effective anti-inflammatory
agents than the other
NSAIDs, and they can cause
the salicylate toxicities.
These are the features
in case you'd like
to review them on
your own at any point.
So let's get into
the widely used
drugs, the non
-salicylate NSAIDs.
They all are weak acids with a
pKa of somewhere
between 3 and 5.
We'll begin with ibuprofen
and naproxen. These are
traditionally categorized
according to their chemistry.
I'm not asking you to remember
the the chemical
categorizations.
It's here so that you can kind
of group this in your mind.
I put the structures
here, of course I
never ask you to memorize
structures. The two
we'll talk about among
the propionic acid
derivatives are
ibuprofen and naproxen.
Takeaway regarding
pharmacokinetics of ibuprofen
and naproxen is that they're
typical of the NSAIDs
class. So hopefully you learned
the class pharmacokinetics,
so now you don't even
have to think about
this except for a couple
of points where they have
drug-specific effects that
I want to point out to
you. So ibuprofen is given
intravenously as well as
******. I will talk about
that on the next slide.
Naproxen has a
longer half-life.
Ibuprofen is a couple
of hours or longer in a
********* infant, but
that we normally expect.
Analgesic and antipyretic
effect are indicated here,
and the duration is
usually six to eight hours.
Compare that to naproxen,
which has a half-life
of usually around 12 hours
in the younger adult.
Analgesic effect is quick.
Analgesic duration of
action is about 12 hours.
therapeutic uses
monotherapy both of them
combination products also
a wide variety of over
-the-counter products
ibuprofen is approved for
people of all ages
remember we want to be
cautious about using
NSAIDs in the older patient
and whoever has
contraindications to its use
Naproxen, the regular
pain fever uses, the
person should be at
least 12 years old.
It can be used at
earlier age for
treating the
juvenile arthritis.
Ibuprofen IV, this is its use.
foreclosure of the patent
ductus arteriosus in
newborns when that is
an appropriate strategy.
So ibuprofen and endomethacin.
These are the two
foreclosure of the PDA.
I would like you to
remember both of those.
Here's something interesting
that's been observed.
Ibuprofen and naproxen
and most likely other
nonspecific NSAIDs taken
before low-dose aspirin
have been shown to inhibit
aspirin binding to COX
-1 and platelets. Oh,
imagine the effect of that.
Ibuprofen and naproxen
reversibly bind the active
site within platelet
COX-1, and aspirin taken
after ibuprofen and naproxen
therefore can't get to
its binding site. So 20
-minute half-life, it's
gone before the ibuprofen
or naproxen dissociates.
Takeaway, low-dose
aspirin should
be taken before the NS NSAID.
So thinking about the
other option, oh gosh, I
forgot to take the low
-dose aspirin and I took
my ibuprofen. Well, when
can I take my low-dose
aspirin? Well, for half
-lives leader. So ibuprofen,
two times four, would
be about eight hours.
Naproxen is going to be,
won't, probably won't
dissociate for another
good 12 hours or so.
Please remember,
both aspirin and
NSAIDs can inhibit the
protective effects,
gastroprotective effects of
prostenoids. Therefore,
putting them together
increases the risk of
GI adverse effects.
I have a scheme here to
help you visualize what
I just described. I'll
go through it with you.
This bar indicates
that the platelet
aggregation has been inhibited.
On here we see the so
-called serine 530, so that's
located in the amino
acid chain at number 530.
Aspirin is bound and
that's going to inhibit
arachidonic acid from
getting in and that will
lead to inhibition of
platelet aggregation.
This is the structure
of the NSAID.
The NSAID is here.
It's blocking arachidonic
acid, and it's
also blocking aspirin
from getting in.
Hours later, the NSAID
dissociates, arachidonic
enters, binds its site, and
produces thromboxane A2.
This is the selective
COX-2 inhibitor,
celecoxib, which is
available in the US.
Celecoxib cannot get into this
binding site. It's too big.
Therefore, aspirin
does enter and is
able to inhibit
platelet aggregation.
Check to knowledge.
How would you sum up
the pharmacokinetic
properties, mechanism of
action, therapeutic uses,
and adverse effects of
ibuprofen and naproxen in
relation to NSAIDs class
in a very few words?
typical class effects
why is the adult
dose of naproxen
typically twice daily as
needed for pain while
ibuprofen is taken
every four to six hours
as needed for pain
naproxen has a longer half
-life it's longer acting a
patient taking a daily
oral low dose aspirin for
prevention of myocardial
infarction also takes ibuprofen
as needed for occasional
muscle pain. What advice should
you give about taking the
two drugs concurrently?
Take the low-dose aspirin
first. Wait at least
30 minutes to take the
ibuprofen or other non
-selective NSAID. Take the
aspirin at least eight
hours after taking
ibuprofen, which is about
four half lives. So if
it's some other NSAID,
then it would be four
half lives of that NSAID.
Chronic or repeated
ibuprofen or other NSAID use
increases the risk of
ulcers and GI bleeding.
This should be the mantra.
Whenever you're talking
about NSAIDs, take the
lowest dose for the lowest
effective dose for the
shortest duration possible
and what is the mechanistic
basis for this advice
aspirin produces its
antiplatelet effect by
irreversibly inactivating
the enzyme the effect lasts
for the life of the platelet
which is a nucleot and
cannot generate replacement
enzymes when When
taken before aspirin, the
non-selective NSAID blocks
aspirin's access to the
site of action at the
serine residue in the
hydrophobic catalytic channel.
Aspirin has an approximately
20-minute plasma half
-life, whereas ibuprofen's
effects last for hours.
Aspirin disappears before
ibuprofen dissociates
from the enzyme,
freeing it to produce
thromboxane A2 and therefore
platelet aggregation.
Aspirin and non
-selective NSAIDs
independently cause GI
bleeding and the risk
increases when
they're used together.
So now the acetic
acid derivatives, I've
starred three,
indomethacin, ketorolac, and
diclofenac. Definitely
worth your while to
remember Remember these,
they're widely used.
The pharmacokinetics property
takeaway, typical
of the NSAIDs class.
I've put some arrows
here to point out areas
that I really want you
to remember because
this will help you
in your clinical
practice, not to
mention on the boards.
We'll start with
endomethacin. I mentioned
before, IV, it is
used for the treatment
of patent ductus
arteriosus in the newborn.
That's the main thing I want
you to take away from here.
Tutorolac, it's
mainly parenteral.
It can be given
intranasally if a
parenteral site
can't be obtained. It
can also be put in
the eye as drops.
So, what is this
feature here? And
I'll get to that
in the next slide.
Poor *********** into
the CSF. We talked
about NSAIDs passing
readily to the CNS,
and it's excreted
largely unchanged in the
urine. That's different
from the others.
Diclofenac is also IV,
let's see they're all IV,
and oral.
Diclofenac comes in
a number of different
forms for systemic
and topical use.
What else do I
want to show you?
That's got a pretty
short half-life.
This is a moderate
half-life, short to
moderate, this is pretty
short also. So in the
neonate, naturally,
it's going to be longer.
Okay, more arrows.
Endomethacin, potent
cyclooxygenase
inhibition. We see more
potent than aspirin.
And these effects have
also been identified, that
it inhibits chemotaxis,
reduces neutrophil migration,
decreases T and B cell
proliferation, decreases
inflammatory cytokines.
These are all excellent
anti-inflammatory effects.
So that all sums up
endomethacin as being a
really good anti-inflammatory.
Acute gout is a big use
of endomethacin because
of this anti-inflammatory
effect. Acute gout can be
really, really painful
and very inflamed joint.
We mentioned closure
of the PDA and as
a tocolytic. Now
what's a tocolytic? It
suppresses *********
labor contractions.
Indomethacin is a
first to second line
a tocolytic. We'll
talk more about
that when we get
to the Repro block.
For now just remember that it
suppresses *********
labor contractions.
Ketorolac affinity for
COX-1 is greater than
affinity for COX-2. it is
used in low doses so low
doses of an NSAID are
effective for pain it takes
higher doses to be for
that anti-inflammatory
action has a short
duration but it is potent
and analgesic effect Please
remember that. Opioid
-like analgesic effects.
So it's great for use,
for management of
acute pain, and for
reduction or instead
of an opioid.
However, it is
associated with a high
risk of GI adverse
effects. Thinking
about this cyclooxygenase
inhibition and
PGE2, PGI2 inhibition
for GI adverse effects.
high risk excellent analgesic
as I mentioned for acute
pain in hospital treatment
it's used in the hospital
it is not used for inflammation
for the treatment of
systemic inflammation
because especially at these
higher doses we get these
GI adverse effects including
perforation. And that
perforation can occur
without warning, even
in individuals who don't
have an apparent GR
contraindication to the use.
And then it can be
used for inflammation
ophthalmically as
drops topically.
All right, diclofenoc
now. Now this one is
a greater affinity for
COX-2 than COX-1. You
see how it's different
than the other two?
Its potency is
similar to that of the
selective COX-2
inhibitor celecoxid,
to give you some
sort of context.
Comparison.
It's good analgesic,
good for arthritis,
anti-inflammatory, and
all of these topical
uses really help
increase its indications.
So adverse effects,
indomethacin, CNS, CNS adverse
effects, many patients are
unable to tolerate these
effects. Severe headache,
dizziness, depression,
nausea, vomiting, heartburn,
diarrhea as you would
expect Ketorolac GI bleeding
can occur at any time
without warning and I'm
going to add here please
remember the perforation
part also perforation it
can be fatal therefore
there is a five-day maximum
duration for Ketorolac.
So a patient may receive
Ketorolac in the hospital
intravenously or I am most
likely and then when the
patient is ready to go home
is stabilized and can go
home yes there is an oral
form available but the
patient will likely be
switched over to a different
NSAID such as ibuprofen.
The elderly are at
greatest risk as usual.
Diclofenac, we see RCNS
effects, GI adverse
effects. Even though it's
COX-2, they can still
occur, and this is going
to be dose dependent.
Cardiovascular risk
is the highest of the
non-selective NSAIDs.
All non-selective NSAIDs
and COX-2 selective
drugs have a substantial
cardiovascular risk
when used regularly.
Hepatotoxicity, increased
serum aminotransferases
with systemic use
is quite common,
and it can cause rash
photosensitivity.
So those are the
three comparisons
between these acetic
acid derivatives.
which NSAID is notable for its
excellent analgesic effects?
Ketorolac, in-hospital
use, IV or IM, usually.
And management of
inflammation, it's not used
for that because it
is associated with GI
bleeding that can occur
any time without warning.
fatalities are reported
elderly at the greatest risk
and Kaltura act should be
used at the lowest effective
dose for the shortest
duration possible no more than
five days higher Kaltura
act doses are needed for
the anti-inflammatory effect
which can lead to serious
adverse effects so it's
not used for that Remember,
COX-1 greater than
COX-2, affinity,
and this is the
inflammatory one.
So it would need high
doses to reach that.
54-year-old man presents
with severe pain,
redness, swelling of
his right big toe,
history of recurrent
acute gouty arthritis.
patients offer treatment
with an NSAID that is a
potent inhibitor of
COX-1 and COX-2, likely
suppresses immune cell
function. Patient replies that
last time you took the
drug, it gave him a
terrible headache and
dizziness and abdominal pain.
What is a described
drug? Yes, indomethacin.
Oops, sorry there.
What two drugs are approved
for closure of ductus
arteriosus and neonates?
That's indomethacin and
ibuprofen. And we have a
62-year-old patient with
localized knee pain due
to mild osteoarthritis.
Applies a topical
NSAID gel to the
area up to four times
daily as needed.
The affinities are COX
-2 greater than COX-1.
And when taken ******,
it's relatively high
cardiovascular risk relative
to the other NSAIDs.
and causes elevated serum
transaminase levels.
What's the drug? And
that's diclofenac.
There we go.
So only one enolic acid
derivative, meloxicam.
It's widely, widely
used. It's long-acting.
The key points
here, preferentially
inhibits COX-2,
similar to zelococcib.
selectivity decreases
at higher doses.
Generally well
-tolerated, gastric
incidence is reduced
at the low doses.
However,
it can lose its
selectivity at the higher
doses and that can increase
GI adverse effects.
And we have our CYP2C9.
I'm not going to ask
you questions about
that. Paroxicam, I listed
here, very long-acting
drug, non-selective.
Let's talk about
celecoxid now. This is a
selective COX-2 inhibitor
I put here in red.
It's got a sulfonamide
moiety here, and therefore,
patients who had a sulfonamide
allergy were excluded in
clinical trials. There's always
this potential suggestion,
suggested potential for
cross-reactivity with
sulfonamide antibiotics. We
don't know, so patients who
have a sulfonamide allergy
should probably not get this
drug. The structure-activity
relationship is that it's
got this bulky structure that
fits in the cyclooxygenase
side pocket, according
to this illustrator here,
and that will provide an
obstruction that prevents
arachidonic acid from entering
the hydrophobic channel.
It doesn't get into
the more narrow
COX-1, that's why
it's selective.
Therapeutic use is the same as
all the rest of them, really.
takeaway. The efficacy
of celecoxin for pain and
inflammation is equivalent
to, not better than,
non-selective NSAIDs. It
has better GI safety, but
the cardiovascular risk and
renal risk is comparable
to ibuprofen and naproxen.
So there's a risk.
Adverse effects, GI,
when taken at low dose
aspirin are in other
words what I'm trying to
say here is GI effects
happen when it's taken
with the low dose aspirin
there's there's no
protection from that renal
hypertension edema all
of this that you see
with NSAIDs in general.
This avoid cabbage
perioperative period,
that's true with
all NSAIDs because
they're already at a
hypercoagulable state.
Proposed mechanism of the
cardiovascular adverse effects.
They do not inhibit the
platelet derived thromboxane
A2. They do inhibit
the disaggregating,
aggregation inhibiting effect
of prostacyclin and that
is going to shift the
balance towards aggregation
and local vasoconstriction
and platelet plug
formation. And there are
probably other effects as well.
Check your knowledge, how
How does Celecoxid compare
to the non-selective NSAIDs
in terms of efficacy?
They're about the same.
How does Celecoxid compare
to non-selective NSAIDs
in terms of GI adverse
risk? It has a reduced
risk, except when it's
taken with other drugs,
like aspirin, that cause
the GI adverse effects.
And we have a little case
vignette. a 30-year-old
recreational runner,
presents with gradually
worsening pain in the
left calf after increasing
weekly mileage while
training for a half marathon.
History and physical
are consistent
with muscle strain
and so forth. So
the patient is given
a prescription.
The patient is
directed to take one
tablet daily for the
shortest duration
possible to relieve
the inflammation.
Clues. COX-1 and
COX-2, but greater
than COX-2, can
take it once daily.
So what is it?
Meloxicam.
And let's quickly go
through acetaminophen,
oral ****** intravenous,
widely distributed, low
plasma protein binding. I'm
getting to the metabolism
on the next slide, renal
excretion of metabolites,
the analgesic effect
lasts four to six
hours, antipyretic
around six hours.
Okay, metabolism.
Acetaminophen is
metabolized mainly by this
glucuronidation and
some by sulfation.
So, the vast majority
of the molecule will
be metabolized by these
phase 2 reactions.
Some of it is
metabolized by CYPs, and
we're interested in
the CYP2E1 because it
is this pathway that
produces this toxic
metabolite, which I
haven't, oops, sorry.
which I have an
arrow to point to.
Now, the toxic metabolite
is rapidly metabolized
by glutathione. Remember,
that's another phase 2
reaction to this mercaptiuric
acid, which is not
active and not toxic. Now,
if glutathione levels are
low or deficient, it will
go down this pathway,
macromolecules
covalent binding two
-cell proteins. So
this drug here, I
mean this metabolite
here, is toxic.
All right, so most people
who take acetaminophen
have plenty of glutathione.
and will, therefore,
not suffer any adverse effects.
Phase II enzymes,
remember, are saturable.
Saturable,
saturable, saturable.
So if these get saturated,
then a greater amount will
go down this pathway, which
increases the risk for
going down the toxic
pathway or if someone is low
on glucuronaciltransferase
well more can get shifted
this way but more can get
shifted this way and what
if cyp2e1 is induced by
another drug that will
increase the amount of
the toxic metabolite which
increases the risk of going
down the toxic pathway,
especially if the patient
is deficient in glutathione.
Risk factors for
glutathione deficiency.
Well, it can be genetic, but we
need to be thinking
about acquired.
Glutathione is depleted
when the body's
detoxification demands exceed
the production. So if a
patient is very ill and
patients with HIV or
often, HIV AIDS, are often
depleted of glutathione
or ingestions of high
doses of acetaminophen,
that's going to saturate
these transferases
and that will shoot more
down the 2E1 pathway.
Nutritional
deficiency, we get the
components of glutathione
from our food.
Chronic metabolic
neurodegenerative diseases
that increase oxidative
stress and impair
antioxidant production.
That's the mechanism.
So I've listed a bunch
of them here. older age,
chronic alcohol consumption
with repeated supra
-therapeutic acetaminophen
doses due to upregulation
of 2E1 increase the
production of NAPQI.
Acute alcohol ingestion
does not appear to be
a risk factor for
hepatotoxicity, but this
can lead to fulminant
or acute liver failure.
And there are many
studies that demonstrate
the prevalence of this
acute liver failure due
to excessive amounts of
acetaminophen intake.
Treatment, N-acetylcysteine.
It restores hepatic
glutathione. It also is a
glutathione substitute.
It enhances the non
-toxic sulfate conjugation,
and it's effective.
You should remember
this antidote.
Actions and effects.
Proposed mechanism of
action. Well, that's not
really well understood,
even after all of
these decades of use.
It inhibits cyclooxygenase
2 in the central
nervous system, but
it does not appear
to bind to the
arachidonic acid site.
Apparently, it may
bind to it and inhibit
a different enzyme
in the pathway.
It causes pain relief.
also result from
interactions with
the endogenous
opioid, possibly.
Possibly with the cannabinoid
receptors may interact
with serotonergic systems.
It's just not clear.
One thing that's clear
is that it doesn't
work in peripheral
tissues. So, it's
not effective for
inflammation. it.
But its analgesic
and antipyretic
effects are pretty
similar to aspirin.
And why doesn't it work
in inflamed tissue?
Well, this is what's
been proposed. High
concentration of lipid
peroxidase in the inflamed
regions will really weaken
acetaminophen action.
And we know
acetaminophen does not
inhibit the
neutrophil function.
Effects. Well tolerated.
Does not appear to cause
platelet dysfunction. Low
incidence of GI side effects.
It's very good for
management of fever and mild
to moderate pain. And it
can be used together with an
opioid analgesic which
allows lower doses of each.
Here is use caution when
prescribing, preparing,
and administering the
IV acetaminophen to
avoid errors that could
result in accidental overdose
and death. This does
have a U.S. boxed
warning, often referred
to as a black box warning.
Hepatotoxicity, we
talked about the severe
toxicity, but it can
cause mild, reversible
elevated hepatic enzymes
with the IV form.
And I've indicated here
the hepatotoxicity.
Analgesic nephropathy
is something that was
seen with a precursor
called finacetin when
it was combined with
aspirin and caffeine.
Tenacetin is metabolized
to acetaminophen, and
that was withdrawn from
the market in 1983.
But it did cause this analgesic
nephropathy when
used regularly.
For instance, people
who suffer from
migraines, this
was a commonly used
drug, and it was taken
fairly regularly.
Acidaminophen does
cross the placenta.
It is considered appropriate
for pain and fever if needed.
And it should be, of
course, the lowest
dose for the shortest
duration of time. It
is considered appropriate
with breastfeeding.
I mean, compatible
It is approved for use
in people of all ages.
and it's a it's really
a good option for people
who are unable to take an
NSAID for pain or fever
CYP inducers so if
CYP2E1 induction can
increase the rate of
metabolism to the NAPQI
warfarin well it is considered
safe there is evidence
to show that daily
acetaminophen use and two
grams a day would be two
extra strength acetaminophen
tablets a day twice a
day it may enhance the
anticoagulant effect, and
cholestyramine, as with so
many different drugs, will
decrease the absorption.
This is a resin that
is not absorbed, and it
binds a lot of drugs, and
it binds bile acids, too.
Your 17-year-old
cousin tells you that
acetaminophen really works
to relieve headaches from
studying too much. She
wonders why it didn't
help with the ankle
sprain pain and swelling
she got from playing
soccer, and ibuprofen did.
What do you tell her?
Acetaminophen doesn't
have anti-inflammatory
actions, basically,
and this is the reason.
How is the relative efficacy of
acetaminophen
typically described?
Analgesic antipyretic,
comparable to aspirin.
How does acetaminophen's
side effect profile
compare with the NSAID's
side effect profile?
Acetaminophen
does not cause the
serious toxicities
associated with NSAID
use and has few
drug interactions.
Acetaminophen is
considered safe
to use in which populations?
Everyone.
Basically, who doesn't have
a contraindication to it?
Why is glutathione
depletion a risk
factor for
acetaminophen toxicity?
Acetaminophen undergoes
saturable metabolism via
glucuronidation, sulfation,
and oxidation via CYPs.
CYP2E1 generates NAPQI, an
unstable toxic intermediate,
which is detoxified by
glutathione S-transferase
to a non-toxic water
-soluble metabolite. If
glutathione levels are
reduced because of genetic or
acquired deficiency, an
APQI may accumulate, leading
to oxidative stress,
mitochondrial dysfunction,
adduct formation, in
other words binding
actually to cellular
macromolecules, and
And that can lead to
hepatocyte necrosis.
And the summary, I'm not
going to go through this
with you in the interest of
time. But it's here for you.
I've tried to organize it
as briefly as possible.
And hopefully it
will give you the big
picture and it will be
triggers for memory.
And I have the answers here,
the questions for you.
I think it covers
the main points.
So thank you very much
for listening to the
two videos on the
pharmacology of the NSAIDs.